Breaking news.
The 10-day ordeal, 12 young
boys and their soccer coach
found alive in a flooded cave in Thailand.
Narrator: Remember when that happened?
It was one of the most difficult
rescue missions of all time,
involving as many as 10,000 people,
and now we know that
rescuers gave the boys a drug
which helped the mission succeed.
That drug was ketamine.
Ketamine was first
synthesized in the 1960s
as an anesthetic, a sedative.
That's why it was so useful
in the rescue mission.
But ketamine actually has
a lot of different uses.
In the '80s, it became
a popular club drug,
gaining nicknames like
Special K and Cat Valium,
and more recently, in early 2019,
a form of ketamine was approved
by the FDA as an antidepressant.
So how does a drug that's so
multipurpose actually work?
Ketamine is what scientists
call a dirty drug.
That means it doesn't just target
one system in your brain, but dozens.
It has a weak effect on opiate receptors
in the dopamine system,
which drugs like heroine
and cocaine target.
But most importantly, ketamine manipulates
a neurotransmitter called glutamate,
earning it the attention of
psychiatrists nationwide.
Glutamate is what many of
the neurons in your brain
use to communicate with each other,
and without it, well, your brain
would essentially shut down
like a city grid without power.
Now, at high doses, ketamine
seems to block glutamate.
That's why it's such an
effective anesthetic.
But in low doses, like what
you might find at a club
or in a spray of the
FDA-approved drug esketamine,
it actually ramps up glutamate production,
and that comes with all
kinds of side effects.
It can make you hallucinate
or feel as though
you're losing touch with reality.
And it might also help build
new connections or synapses
between neurons, electrifying
new parts of that city grid.
Chadi Abdallah: When people
are stressed for a long time
or when they suffer from
depression for a while,
they start losing these connections,
and when we give them ketamine 24 hours,
they reverse. Now they look
like more a normal brain.
So we believe that perhaps ketamine
is working by regenerating
these connections
that are needed for
normal brain functioning.
Narrator: And that could make ketamine
one of the best drugs out
there for treating depression.
This isn't how other antidepressants work.
Medications like Prozac and
Zoloft take weeks if not months
to kick in, and they regulate serotonin,
another chemical in the brain,
which scientists have
long tied to depression.
These more traditional drugs
may work for some people,
but not for everyone.
In fact, as many as 4
million American adults
have treatment-resistant depression.
And for them, well, ketamine might be
the only drug out there
that can provide relief.
That's according to Doctor Andre Atoian.
He's the founder of Ketamine Specialists,
a clinic where he administers
ketamine to patients with
mood disorders, pain, and addiction.
Andre Atoian: Ketamine is
the agent that works when
most others have failed.
It is something that really
allows us to give patients
a sort of new hope 'cause a
lot of people that I treat
have basically already tried everything,
and they're in this situation
where nothing's really working,
and they're suffering, they're miserable.
Narrator: So it's hard to
deny that ketamine's effect
on depression sounds promising,
and, clearly, it's a useful sedative.
But here's the thing...
Nolan Williams: As far as
effect, it's, you know,
there's still a lot we don't know.
Narrator: That's Doctor Nolan Williams,
an assistant professor of psychiatry
at the Stanford University Medical Center.
He says that because ketamine
manipulates so many different
receptors in the brain,
it's been hard to nail down all of them.
So it's still unclear how it
might affect different patients
both short- and long-term,
and researchers still haven't figured out
how to preserve its benefits
as an antidepressant.
Abdallah: The challenge is how to maintain
these new connections.
Is it to give ketamine repeatedly?
We know that we cannot give it every day,
that's like substance of abuse,
because then it will harm the brain.
Narrator: So while FDA
approval is considered
a victory for the millions of people
with treatment-resistant depression,
doctors still caution that
ketamine should only be used
as a last resort.